[Music]
nature is at cop26 to find answers to
the climate science questions you've
been asking
one question came from dr meisner my
question to you
concerns risk why is the risk as a topic
but more explained in the medical
profession this would be the point where
we would initiate ict studies for
clinical data and try to get information
on what effects and side effects our
different interventions cause
dr meisner's insight into how the
medical field would gather data about
risk using rcts or randomized controlled
trials got us imagining the earth as a
sick patient now one sick planet is of
course very different to a population of
sick patients but it struck us that the
climate scientists do do something
loosely similar to an rct just digitally
they build models
so we went searching for modelers in the
hopes that they could give dr meisner
some insight into how a climate
scientist calculates risk
and we found richard betts who leads
climate impact research at the uk's met
office
we can't do experiments on the real
earth of course we only have one we
can't do a traditional control
experiment but we can use our models of
climate and weather
as a virtual laboratory
both to explain past changes in climate
and make assessments of future changes
richard described how he builds his
models so essentially the same
mathematically based models that we use
for the weather forecast in the met
office so a whole range of
well-established equations uh for
the law of physics fluid dynamics and
also the representation of biological
processes in the carbon cycle and so on
and approximations for some of the more
kind of detailed processes to do with
cloud formation
and the changes of water from liquid
water to water vapor and precipitation
and so on
the energy balance of the earth
basically the whole operation of the
global climate system between the
atmosphere the oceans and the biosphere
the global carbon cycle
so we can represent that within within
our models we use
the fortran computer language up to two
million lines of fortran computer code
hundreds maybe thousands of people have
worked on the metals modeling over the
years these huge models do their best to
account for all the variables but unlike
in randomized controlled trials in
medicine climate scientists can't
directly see the outcome of the
interventions they're testing only what
their models predict might happen but
they have ways to try to make up for
that limitation now in these models you
can't get a perfect representation you
don't know all the numbers perfectly
accurately
so we have to have multiple versions of
the models
where we have a range of many of the key
input parameters
there's also other models as well
produced by other centers
using all these together we can actually
assess a range of outcomes in both of
the past and future climate so we can
drive the climate model with passive
climate forcing so how much co2 has
risen over the last hundred and fifty
years or so uh how the the the
sun has changed how volcanoes have
impacted the climate as they've erupted
in
recent years decades and centuries and
then scenarios of future changes of the
buildup and greenhouse gases to
different levels with different
assumptions about whether we cut
emissions or continue to immediately
increase to
emissions and it's by comparing all of
these models that scientists can start
to make assessments of risk
we can use a whole set of models to look
at a range of responses both in terms of
the global climate and regional climates
changing extreme weather and look at the
different ranges of possibilities and
it's very important not to look at
the average of all the models that can
give you some idea perhaps where you
might be most confident but in terms of
risk assessment you want to look at
things that are possible even if they're
not the most likely you want to look at
the tales of the distribution what is
the
five percent probability of
occurrence and a lot of our working
forward risk assessments so that is
really crucial to take that related
approach